.
A GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON I WILL GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED ON THE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES AT
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE CAN YOU
ESTABLISH QUORUM PLEASE
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
ARE HERE.
TALK TO CHOI.
ARAMBULA HERE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
LAST [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BERMAN.
LOOK AT A CLIP.
MORE WEIGHT ON THE AUTHOR SHOULD
BE ON HIS WAY [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
I KNOW.
THE ONLY ONE WILL [inaudible]
WHAT
?
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US --
FOR THIS HEARING THAT WE ARE
HOLDING PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO WE
HAVE ONE BILL UP A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON.
WE ALLOWED HIM TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL.
EACH OF THE WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
MAY ADD ON THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BY STATING ONLY THEIR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
MISTER PATTERSON WELCOME THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AT FIRST OF
ALL I APOLOGIZE.
I FEEL VERY BAD ABOUT THAT --
BOB THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT TO MAKE IT
AS QUICK AS I CAN NOT IT'S BEEN
AWHILE SINCE YOU BROUGHT HER THE
BILL.
I WAS PRETTY HURT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY BY THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR THE BILL HAS A HAS NOW
BEEN APPLIED TO ADDITIONAL CARE
FACILITIES AS WELL AS A SIX BED.
THE SEWAGE FOR THE ELDERLY.
UP YOU KNOW THE SIX BEDS PROVIDE
COMFORTING SAFE ALTERNATIVES FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
VERY QUICKLY --
PER [inaudible]
A THE BILL IS THAT IT ALLOWS
FACILITIES TO BE PROPERLY
STAFFED --
WHEN EMPLOYEE SICK?
LEAVE OTHER THINGS ENSURES
OPERATORS HAVE A RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITY WHERE THEY CAN
TRANSFER EMPLOYEES BACK AND
FORTH.
UP THE DEPARTMENT HAD REQUESTED
BILL ALSO APPLY TO ADDITIONAL
CARE FACILITIES WE DID THAT AND
DIALED.
WITHOUT PEER TO AT TESTIFIED
SUPPORT REX AND GOLDEN BOB NEVER
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS AND I'M
GOING TO ASK IF THEY CAN BE
BRIEF.
OKAY HIGH ROCKS AND GOLD
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS IS AN
ASSOCIATION WAS FORMED FOUR
YEARS AGO OF SMALL FAMILY TYPE
SETTINGS FOR THE ELDERLY WE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS NOW AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BOB REPRESENTING SIX BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO ADD.
OKAY.
THAT BY THEIR ANY THAT WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
NO MISTER PATTERSON YOU
MICHAEL'S.
ARE PLEASER PUT PLEASE VOTE I
THANK YOU.
I MADAM SECRETARY CAN CALL THE
ROLL RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
BUT I'M GLAD I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE THERE'S THERE'S
AYE STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE THE BILL ITSELF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OUT THE
BUILT.
WE ARE CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS AND OF THE BILL GETS
OUT.
FIVE TWO IF YOU. FIVE TWO ZERO
TO THE FLOOR THANK YOU.
CAN WITHOUT WILL GO AHEAD AN
ADJOURNED THE MEETING A FEW
MENTORS IS THAT --
TWELVE FORTY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
I DON'T EVEN THINK.
RENDON REMOVAL CRAP.
I THINK SOMEONE [inaudible]
RICARDO [inaudible]
ONLY [inaudible]
THEY NEVER
[inaudible]
I KNOW.
AND THAT.
PEOPLE REALLY WANT ANOTHER KIND
[inaudible]
PART
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINK YOU
KNOW THAT LIVE IN [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT THIS IS MY LIFE.
YEAH WAS SAY.
ONE THING.
I HOPE I REALLY LIKED IT THAT IF
YOU GOT IT EVEN HIGHER
[inaudible]
I THINK